taste buds they com to the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two fools going to
fight but only one food can be right
T hey welcome to t a s e buds we got a
special guest in the house today our boy
our man Mikey fenya hey guys comedian
friend brother fish
fan someone uh new special uh coming out
coming out out don't let me down this is
dropping October November
oh so this is before that yes November
9th is special on YouTube right now it's
on 800 pound gorilla pay what you want
but it'll be free on YouTube November
night well then I think they got to go
watch it now and pay what they want sure
but also because watch it five times on
YouTube exactly yeah watch it pay to
watch it and then go click it 35,000
times only because of my terrible
schedule I have like five specials I
have to watch in the bank one is
completely yours I apologize believe me
it's with everybody but I will say I saw
clips of it I saw
it gorgeous I appreciate it I did it at
Fairfield theater company did it all
myself DIY yeah went in there don't tell
everybody that don't tell every comedian
we know how you did this because no no
no it's it's insane it's insane yeah but
I did a pretty amazing thing he he has a
I will I mean it's let's talk about it
yeah he he he was able to put this whole
thing
together for an
amount it look it's un I mean it looks
like unbelievable and it was for I think
like the cheapest special I've heard
someone do is probably like five six
times less than that like and it's not
even you just found the right venue the
right people the right this got you know
and it came together and I'm telling you
man yeah like yeah I'm telling you you I
I have never heard anyone do it and it
look that good for what you did thank
you and I'm very uh I'm not a I'm not I
never use the word I'm proud of anything
proud of this good you should be you
know I I don't ever have that feeling
but I did all of it like start to finish
helped the editing the audio picking
everything the lights all of it it
worked out great I worked with candy
from New York comedy club on it she
helped a ton but I'm really stoked for
it so yeah thank you um yeah and so I
mean if you Mike you are on uh what
episode did we do last time was it lunch
lunch vers dinner breakfast lunch dinner
oh yeah so Mike is a returning uh uh
guest obviously and also if you've
toured with me or or the tender or the
Impractical Jokers Mike you've seen him
on T for years Mike worked on the show
for many years uh I think might still be
I can't say anything but beautiful no I
don't know like I don't know did you
talk was there anything left that's
offline it's all offline I don't know if
there I'm just going to sit R you had to
do were huh I don't know if there's
anything bank that you had or if there's
going to be something else again yeah we
we'll figure that out we'll figure that
out absolutely cool so all right so I
know what you guys are talking about but
sure I'm not sure I do either but yeah
no inside joke with the fact bubbles pop
up you know it's like aie Osborne and uh
whatever and the
Avengers yeah I didn't know what you
talking call back to last episode he was
talking smack you know what I I realized
that you didn't say anything about in
the first episode I was waiting I didn't
want to call it out myself I'm your
brother in Jorts today oh yeah said
either wow so what you're coming around
on these things I mean I've had these
for years I just I have two pairs of
Jorts by the way Brothers in Jor it's
oober it's 84° outside disting world is
crumbling yeah something's something's
very weird I flew out third Friday
during when everything was flooding
literally pulled into JFK and it was
like don't leave your house yeah when
the Deluge hit and like Brooklyn was
under like it was insane and then flying
home from Fort Lauderdale Fort
Lauderdale was flooded yeah I mean
literally there you guys get impacted by
that the flooding anyone anybody no
downtown by the entrance to the tunnel
oh oh yeah I saw some clips how'd you
like it awesome right dry bikes of
course yep I was worried that it was
going to hurt the bar cuz the bar is yes
yes nothing wow that's wild I was
thinking about that yeah not a drop I
thought about the seller I thought about
a lot of places that so many of my
friends tweeted me P texted me pictures
of out right outside their windows or
their buildings and dude it was like
soup we were those cars just floating
ridiculous we were at skankfest yeah oh
we got to get into that a little bit and
Paul Italia my business partner was also
there cuz the stand did shout outs to
the stand shout out to scank Fest the
stand uh sponsored SC was one of the
sponsors so they had a room called The
Stand room at uh skankfest anyway we're
at we're in theen I was on the road I
I'm sorry I missed it but apparently
this was one for the absolute agest
possibly the CRA funnest one ever most
greatest stand up weekend of my life
ever wow I got to hear about this show
that you and also uh just V like as a
vacation just fun
thing vacation I wanted all summer I
actually went to for work and ended up
having the release and fun of the
vacation let's talk about that a little
bit before we get into the battles but
anyway uh we're Paul and I are in the
green room and it's like it's like
midnight Vegas time sure so like so then
midnight so we're pretty toasty yeah but
I'm saying on the East Coast it's 3:00
a.m. okay and uh we're we're all pretty
toasty at this point and we're talking
I'm talking to some people he's like
across the room and I'm talking to some
people about the floods and I go yeah I
look crazy man and somebody goes is your
bar okay and I go oh yeah and I
literally turn and I I scream like
through I go Paul did our bar get
flooded he goes no like okay we're good
I wonder how many Vegas life start like
that like midnight in Vegas everything's
[__] at home and you're like I think
I'm just going to stay here now really
it didn't even dawn on me I was so up in
the gang a place people just stay um so
you went Friday Saturday Sunday is that
Thursday Friday
Saturday wow nights you SLE you had four
sleeps there brother I'm not lying I
slept for 2 hours on Friday night I
slept for 3 hours sick to hear it I know
I slept for 3 hours on FR Thursday and I
slept for two hours Friday I slept for
three and then Saturday and Sunday I
slept like regular question you you guys
have I got some ear on you guys are you
are you still in the phase where okay oh
I only got four hours sleep last night
I'll still I'll still go out the next
running gun this at the other are you
still in my face no you are yeah why not
because you're young exactly no I agree
I was there um you are not you're saying
you're not you you need I just went to a
wedding this past weekend I was asleep
by 1 okay so you don't if you don't have
one of those nights out like dancing
kicking your heels off whatever that you
do I yeah I do but it's like it's
rare the next day oh there's there's not
even it's not even a cards for me
anymore to not get a certain amount of
sleep exactly because it's worth more
than anything else yep really you have a
regiment in your life shock to hear I
do listen I'm not dude dude I mean I'm
rubbing your glue I don't know what to
say to you no no no no no I'm similar I
need a good night's sleep I'm not a guy
that's like I'll burn the candle at BIR
both ends I don't care like I'm not well
I burn the candle at both ends but
that's why I need to sleep right you
know but I I have departed from
obviously you know you you're still a
man about town but I'm telling you
something I'm not a man about I'm a man
about suburbs had you told me going into
it that's what you're going to do I
would have said I I no I I can't I can't
I can't I would have panicked I'm so
excited I was there
yeah and the first
night well I heard I heard this I heard
there I heard there were I heard there
was shows for the record books I heard
that you might have uh been involved
with uh possibly meeting a lady I heard
there was
tattoos I heard there was and I got to
hear this show that you andari put up
that I heard was one of the funniest and
best shows ever conceived and created
and I want to know details so this is
the story I'll tell about the first
night okay we we got we got there me Ari
Steve Ren so just for our listeners
skankfest is a Comedy Festival uh that
the most I guess LS J Gomez Rebecca
Trent Evans um who from this
leg of skanks podcast created about 5
years ago Creek in the cave exactly it's
kind of this like alternative like kind
of punk rock kind of thing that
independent independent Festival very
independent um that has just gained
steam because it's like for Comics by
comics and everyone it's a Love Fest
right yeah it was a couple years in
Brooklyn and and it's gotten bigger and
bigger started it started over here it
started over here in Long Island City
right yeah I did the first it was just
okay that's the okay that's the alarm
Jes all right so pimp what is happening
to us going to happen to us now nothing
it was some dumb conspiracy like y 2K
part two this is a
test yeah everybody's phone was going to
ring at 220 yeah all right cuz you said
something was going to happen to us well
they said at the same time the hydron
collider was going to do some
experiment I don't know the hydron
collider what the hell is that some
crazy conspiracy online space cam is it
are we good uh let's check in in a few
minutes okay
weird while we're talking just scan the
internet let us need to call my mother
just put in trending and just see and I
want you to remember the last episode
when I said I'm worried that my wrist is
numb because of the eye watch and you
said there's no way that's possible look
at what just happened literally
everybody's phone across the country
rang at the same time do you remember
last time that happened was like Trump
was just like hey just texting you now
just to let you know I can do it do you
guys remember that yeah we just got a
text across all our phones it was like
this is the White House what's up like
yeah that's the last time I got like a
group silver over so so we got to we got
to move because we had a lot to cover
here but but but we um we uh I like to
keep it timely but we but anyway yes
there it always feels like you're in a
rush I want you to settle in let you
have CU you have no concept of time I do
none we're
fine fine we got we got two battles in
the final I mean what the hell s it over
and over or something happening that we
should be know everybody's phones at
different probably different carriers
okay the TV your watch going to
explode what the hell yo the first night
of any anything multi night you always
go I'm going to go easy and you gos to
the wall no matter what so so it started
me
Ari Rena
easy Tommy
Pope uh
I think that's it no somebody else was
there I'm blanking don't get anyway um
we went to dinner at like six I met Ari
at 5 MH started drinking with
Ari we we sit down at dinner we get we
get the steakhouse you start getting
bottles of wine and stuff then we go to
the opening night party you opened with
wine we're no I opened with ar with
whiskies and then we got martinis at the
barn in the Sak house then we sat down
and started drinking wine then we went
to the party and we were drinking we
went back to hard
liquor then they had an after party yeah
every night see this is your mistake
though 10 years I I was behind the bar
10 years but this is your mistake though
you can't do skank fests like that you
got to go with the flow I'll go with the
flow yeah well that's the thing I love
people that go oh God shots I can't do
it let me smoke an entire joint to the
head I'm sorry in in between the six
drinks I had I at Virginia Slims okay
fine fair enough anyway so we uh Paul he
was spoking anyway we go to the
Afterparty and Lewis is like we're doing
every night the after party the the
party the have any spots open no I
didn't have any spots open Lewis goes
the Afterparty every night is at
peppermint hippo strip club and we're
going to Spearmint Rhino peppermint
hippo what no I I've heard of yeah wow
there's a new large animal with a minty
Twist on the Block wait until the
butterscotch zebra opens I literally
can't tell this it's going to take
literally 35 minutes okay it's going to
take just tell them the bridge version
you know a lot of the Pod gets taken up
with you saying what you can't do and
how much we have to hurry up and less
with the details that we're all craving
okay all right it's okay we'll we'll
calibrate yeah fine fair enough I want
you to relax have a good time tell I
want to I I'm very interested in this
weekend I'm sure people are too it's a
big big that's your attitude well this
is also going to come out a month and a
half later but nobody knows the details
it's not like they're getting the
details elsewhere yeah oh they got
details are out it's a fun it's a fun
ROM the details are out pimp knew what
happened when I walked in the room today
it's a fun romp of a weekend that you
had take us on the ride I'm going to
take you on part of the ride we uh we
went to the we then got busted to the
strip club we were in the strip club
dancing I started spending is we all the
uh staff and comedians in the festival
is that what is yeah just so I start
spending what I can only refer to as an
ungodly amount of money at the strip
club they got you that's how they get
you this night ended with did you think
that one of them really liked you no
okay were you gon were you gonna pay for
her law school yeah no I was just in the
zone I didn't I was like whatever what
zone Joe were you in the strip club Zone
okay yeah shitfaced I was having a
called hippopotamus what is it this is
the uh the minty the minty all right
guys where the hell is
this guys stop hold on guys this is why
I don't want to tell the story we're
digressing in eight directions in four
parts of the room let me just tell the
story I'll get to this let me just tell
you got it baby yeah focus focus focus
I'm telling you story here I've been
focused since the beginning listen to me
so we go to the strip club this night
ends H at 5:30 in the
morning this is why I don't want to tell
the story he wants to hear the story and
through the through the whole thing he
wants to go this sounds so tell me the
story Jo I think it sounds awful of
thinking if I stayed up till 5:30 it has
nothing to do with your story I'm
excited about your story I want to hear
about it I take nothing away from you
being and the night ending there I can't
have a semi quiet reaction to something
that you have to stop down and chastise
me let's go to let's go let's go get
distracted let go Statler over here was
that unwarranted was that unwarranted
maybe a little bit thank you wait me he
means you no well ventia said no me no
he was me going o was enough for him to
be like that's why I don't want to tell
this story you're going
to I don't know all right
little a little bit I thought I could
feelings as you told the story I'm sorry
hold on hold on hold on hold on tell the
story 5:30 in the morning this the night
ends yes and no the night doesn't end
this is what I'm getting at and nor was
I awake is what I'm getting at I'm he's
out 5:30
a.m. I am woken up in the corner of the
strip club by two strippers all my
friends have left I'm the only one still
there and then I am coerced by those two
strippers to then get another $600 worth
of laugh dances they woke you up for
which I happily did w I'm so sorry I'm
so sorry everyone has left you yes you
fell asleep you're alone yes you've been
abandoned you're in a place of business
still you get nuded awake from a slumber
two by two and you wake up and then you
you take van and then you take $600 and
you go back into it they were the two
most beautiful women I've ever been
woken up by 5:30 in the morning
in wow so I go I by the way this is the
night where I'm just on the
eyewatch I leave I go outside to call an
Uber I realize the Uber app has been
removed from the eye watch I can't get
it over I'm like God damn it man so I'm
outside it's 6 got ter line it's 6:15
I'm standing just on immediate no no cab
line I'm just trying to find is it Off
the Strip oh we're like way downtown
yeah we're not no yeah we're not on the
Strip we're like usually they have cabs
pull up not at 6:15 they don't all right
uh yeah it's 6:15 you're kind of on your
own at that point yeah so do you have a
handle on what you spent that night in
total oh yeah you want to ra no I'd
rather not say well you already just
told us you got woken up and spend $600
I said it on Legion of ganks I I
attempted to pass a bucket around to to
recollect I saw a picture of it are we
over for the night are we over 1500 yes
600 on the just wow dude he got he play
he hit snooze and paid 600 yeah I'm
wondering when are you over are you over
wait this is this is all got to be for
the women you didn't drink this kind of
I know the drinks are2 was drinks CU a
drink when you went back for lap air
they'd be like you got to buy the girl
drink you have to buy two drinks to be
like you to do anything show me in the
contract where it says that well tell
the 600 pound bouncer that that you I'll
tell them I'll tell them I don't have
buy anyone anything I'm happy to uh to
to support the the woman and get this
exchange B of this exchange yeah I
support the why do I have to why do I
have to uh hydrate her so here's
why here's where the know your employer
should provide them okay I I get back to
my hotel room at 7 a.m. can I ask one
thing yes how was it that they just left
you asleep like why wouldn't they say
wake up come with us we had all sort of
lost track of one another in this place
everybody kind of went off in their own
Direction you chose you chose a corner
to Cur it like it was like the Six Flag
Safari you had the hippo what peppermint
hippo do you remember falling asleep at
all do I remember when sleep Joe made an
appearance no I don't I got to be honest
SE no we haven't seen sleepy Joe in
quite some time yeah I don't know why
sleepy Joe is back sley Joe is back so I
get back to the room it's like 700 a.m.
I'm just like oh God damn it and I go to
sleep and at 10: a.m. my phone rings cuz
I I had it on silent but I didn't
realize it was ringing to my iPad was
set
up this thing blares I'm like oh my God
what is that it was so loud and uh I
look and it's Alex from Legion skanks
okay the producer okay and I'm
like [__] what is this like what what is
oh man what is this this is something to
do with the festival so I answered she's
like do you want to come do Legion of
skanks to kick off at 12:00 p.m. I'm
like yeah I guess
so get out of bed I'm like how'd you
find the wherewithal baby it's Vegas I'm
like let's go this is where this is
separat the from W hung over to the
point of the shakes the nausea the
headache like I can't get up I wasn't
shaking or anything I didn't feel great
I went to The Green Room I saw Dave
Smith I sat with him we we started
having a whiskey all right at like 11:45
a.m. okay but you spent basically a
Dodge neon's worth of money at the strip
club and then you also had 2 hours sleep
so the combination of the Dodge Neon
worth of liquor and the 2 hours sleep
you were still functioning I was like
all right I'm going to do this bit with
the bucket and I'm going to this is
going to be funny and like I'm going to
all right this is going to be great okay
so then I go I do Legion of ganks that's
a story in and of itself that I can't
that we trust me we don't have the time
okay just believe me on that I believe
you the uh all
right I'm I'm trying to I'm trying just
trust me uh that night we do shows that
night it was sh it was amazing it was
just I did what your with Jay I did the
crowd mic it was amazing all the energy
was good vibe was good the shows are
great everyone's banging on all s there
a buzz going on show fun show fun show
all the friends are there yeah I did
show that night and then I did what then
and then that night we went out it was I
went out with aelo that night yeah me
ailio and tone Bell and TJ Miller ended
up at a place on the Strip tone Bell was
on the on the on the oh awesome we ended
up on the Strip somewhere at like 400
a.m. and we got a we got table surface
at this place the Dance Floor was empty
and tone was dancing by himself for an
hour we got bottle service we went
upstairs we we're gambling next thing I
know dude it's 900 a.m. and I'm like oh
my God reaction I'm sorry I didn't say
don't have
a do it in my shirt holy [__] just let
him talk I go back I go to
bed that was another one of those nights
me we all went to the me TJ Paul went to
uh Aaron Berg we went to a
steakhouse and we it was that's how the
night started before the shows and I was
like we were just off to the race let me
ask a question Vegas uh there's
sometimes there's a festival in a place
where the places are all like you know
four five three blocks from each other
everyone's walking around and you're
seeing Vegas is way bigger so if it
seems to me like like remember they had
the um in Brooklyn I think it was the
skankfest where it was in like the same
three buildings and it was contained so
you but this is like oh it's probably
all over the place right no no it was in
this comp that that complex oh so so the
full Festival was in one area yeah
there's there's a complex and then
inside that complex is a multi-roomed
venue that has tons of rooms in it okay
like
tons um so and then they do stuff down
in the courtyard of the complex itself
and down in the courtyard it looks like
Thunderdome you're surrounded by open
yeah the pictures were incredible halls
and stuff right that go up three
stories so the shows were just amazing
the standup shows were incredible um the
crowds were incred I did what's your I
did uh you know what dude live with
Bobby like it was um the crowds
scheduled on these or was everyone just
you were just jumping on most of it was
scheduled but here or there you'd pop on
something but people are running on
stage and stuff and it was it's wild
right Crowds Are they they they this
thing has grown over the years with
Legion of skanks it's comes from Legion
of skanks but it's bled into skank fet
itself like you'll be on stage just
doing a set and like you'll have a joke
that hits and the crowd starts chanting
your name it's like it's like comedy
wrestling it's wild and the nicest
sweetest the most endearing fans ever
like none of it feels like none of it
when I see chanting and stuff people are
like oh is it like aggressive it's like
no it's awesome it's so it's they're
happy to be there and they're happy that
there's such access to the to a lot of
their favorite comics and it's kind of
like a Love Fest really right yes so um
lot of people can be intimidated by just
what the skanks do on their podcast and
what what the assump of a lot of their
fans are yes but it kind of bucks that
kind of stereotype yes so uh last night
me and Ari did so the footage you saw
was the very end of the festival which
was the last event was the goddamn
Comedy Jam that's an very lovely woman I
met on Legion of skanks who uh I will
say I had an encounter with uh because
the details are going to Sidetrack us
way too much right now so just going to
have to trust me on that uh but she's
wonderful her name is Nikki Fox anyway
how many times did you did you encounter
her just once but we had a great time
but this was in the twice during that
once this was in the courtyard and there
were people filling the all the way up
standing on the rails that's cool that's
like that scene from Cocktail yeah and
then a sea of people around the stage
and we did The Comedy Jam I did time of
my life from Dirty Dancing it was it was
insane it was insane
um that was how the festival ended um
and then um not with me singing I just
mean with this event and then um before
this though is when Ari and I did our
secret show okay let's get into it it
was
called Secret Show I can't give you
you're not get the only details I'll
give you are this it was called Ari and
Joe [__] on any comedian you tell us I
know that's why I want to know details
no that's not how the show works you had
to be there no phone nothing leaks from
the
room okay I wish you would have okay so
you could tell me off a
no that's not how the show Works give me
a
break no that's not how the show Works
call me n Carter and give me a break all
right no the show is a secret show did
you did people know what the title of
the show was yes so why was it secret it
was jam packed why was it secret we
policed the room for phones no no I mean
how was it oh oh I see what you mean you
mean secret as as far as nothing gets
out of nothing leaves this room okay
well you were in Vegas hence the
anonymity for us to feel free to [__] on
whoever they said let's who who you [__]
you know we picked we picked people and
if you think that when this ends you're
not going to tell me all the details
right you have another thing coming when
this ends I'm getting out of here 45
minutes after I needed to today with the
s i i uh we're 35 minutes late and we
still haven't even started the damnn
battles yet Jo R things I had the time
of my life with the Trans woman he
jacked off and came on during skankfest
wow guys we're listen I love you we're
we we're you know what you're right
Butterfinger go well I told you I didn't
want I told you we're going to get too
digressed with this I relax we're not
going into it folks I want to talk to
you about game time a favorite sponsor
here at the tastebuds podcast I love
going to events all kinds of events uh
usually for me it's music but I also do
go see comedy shows Believe It or Not
folks an established comic like me still
pays his way in once in a while you know
what I mean uh and I will go to the
occasional sporting event even even
though I'm not a huge sports fan theater
oh I like theater anyway here's my point
because my schedule is crazy I don't
like to buy tickets way in advance
because I'm always afraid something's
going to come up and I won't be able to
go to the show I love game time for this
reason game time helps you get the last
minute tickets so you're not feeling
pressure to buy these things in advance
and when you're buying them last minute
with game time they're letting you know
you're getting the best available ticket
for the best available price they're
showing you what it's going to look like
from where you're sitting you just know
everything's going to be a okay uh you
know what can I say it's just a great
service for somebody who doesn't like to
commit and boy is that me anyway last
minute tickets Flash Deals Zone deals uh
and easy to find and you know it's the
lowest pric again guaranteed event
cancellation protection job loss
protection Etc so check it out take the
guest work out of buying tickets with
Game Time download the game time app
create an account use code tastebuds for
$20 off your first purchase terms apply
again create an account and redeem code
taste buds t a s BS for $20 off download
game time today last minute tickets
lowest price guaranteed folks if you
want to hear a phrase that goes
something like where'd you get that this
holiday season you're going to want to
look into Uncommon Goods Uncommon Goods
is your secret weapon here to make your
holiday shopping stressfree by scowering
the globe for the most remarkable and
truly unique gifts for everyone on your
list whether you're shopping for a
secret Santa which by the way I get
involved in secret santa uh usually at
Christmas I get involved in aalana with
my family it's hard to find a gift for a
certain price that you think will be
unique uh that doesn't look like you
just wandered randomly into a generic
store and bought anything that fit the
price point here's where Uncommon Goods
is going to know exactly what you're
shopping for uh and and provide you
exactly what you want how Again by
giving you access to some truly unique
cool stuff I found a whiskey making kit
uh I found hot sauce I found a really
cool uh popcorn bowl uh journals uh all
kinds of cool interesting office type
stuff just lifestyle gifts uh that are
that are very unique and very cool they
take that sort of thing you might find
again in in a store somewhere you know
along your travels as you Traverse the
malls or whatever and they give you the
most cool and interesting version of
that thing and that's what I really like
and then there's stuff on there that not
going to find in any mall or anywhere
you're only going to find it uh by them
providing it to you from these unique uh
providers they're getting this stuff
from anyway uh they're giving you the
most unique version of these things why
because you're getting them from from
artists the by shopping at Uncommon
Goods you're supporting artists instead
of big box stores you're supporting
you're supporting independent businesses
uh These Fine products are often made in
small patches so you know know it's
something truly unique that you're
getting that you're not going to find at
the mall all right so shop now before
these things sell out and get it for the
holiday season all right Uncommon Goods
products that are uh high quality that
are unique and often handmade in the
United States uh and they just I don't
know they have meaningful out of thee
ordinary gifts I just think it's very
cool anyway get 15% off of your next
gift go to uncommongoods.com
tastebuds that's Uncommon Goods ./
tastebuds for 15% off don't miss out on
this limited time offer Uncommon Goods
we are all out of the ordinary I will
say this to you please even though I
previously said that I could not tell
you anything that took place in The
Secret Show yes a lot of what was said
I've already expressed to you in text
messages wow so I was a topic of conv no
no I'm not saying I expressed it to you
about you I'm saying I've expressed it
to you in text messages about other
comedians over the over the yeah I know
that's why I'm like tell me I want to
see what came out in the wash all right
uh all right let's get to the battle
let's do it yeah yeah there's more stank
we'll talk about it another time yeah
anyway okay uh so Mike we've been doing
the congrats again on the special we've
been doing a candy bracket uh for
Halloween uh so explain this yeah I will
say though because we we've done
Powerhouse candies in the past so if
you're saying how does this not make the
tournament we didn't want to repeat
candies so we we we took eight ones that
we haven't done before and uh the last B
the last ones and just refresh my memory
was Nestle Crunch versus Hershey with
almonds oo Nestle Crunch won that yes it
was Butterfinger
versus take
five I would go take five I would too it
got trounced by Butterfingers shocking
we did Junior mins versus Rolo Junior
your Ms I would too it got trounced by
Rolo and the last one was Milky Way
versus peanut butter
Twix Milky Way really yeah I'm not a
peanut butter peanut butter oh wait
peanut butter Twix is just regular Twix
no regular Twix just doesn't have the
peanut butter it has caramel ah yeah I
think I would have went with I'll tell
you what they did they did mess up with
peanut butter Twix they used to be a
vanilla cookie bar inside they change it
to a chocolate and that I will agree was
a misstep I would give both of those I
lost I thing I won was crunch I love n
crunch uh he won so his Butterfinger
Rollo and Milky Way are all his but now
we receded okay and now it's going to be
uh Nestle Crunch versus Milky Way yes
right okay and Butterfinger versus Rolo
okay and then the two winners are
obviously it's the finale and the reason
we paired them like this was because we
argued last episode what the better
combination of things was Butterfinger I
mean sorry peanut butter and chocolate
or caramel and chocolate sadly both my
choices won so I have to pick I mean
geez we well wait a minute who would you
take in this battle I would take
Butterfinger over Rolo yeah I think Rolo
just it's not enough to it for me to get
excited even Butterfinger even though I
don't like it cuz I hate the way it
feels in my teeth at least it feels like
it has some substance to what is
Butterfinger I mean because I would
absolutely don't know we think it's tree
bark I would take I would take Milky Way
over the Nestle Crunch any day of the
can well I I still would take Nestle and
not of course yeah can I say
Butterfinger is probably the only candy
that while eating it I'm like I'm so
sick of this goddamn candy oh that's a
really good point I literally I'll eat
rollos it's a decent sized bar they're
they are big bars and by the time you're
about halfway through you're like I've
had enough of whatever this is what this
glue stick I'm eating I don't like it I
even though I won with Butterfinger and
I also won with Rolo I have to take Rolo
in this just to be a man of my word
because I said that the caramel and
chocolate combo is better than the
peanut butter chocolate combo I love
Butterfinger but I will say that Rolo
has t has held a special place in my
life when I was a kid it was my favorite
uh candy
ever in the comments if Rolo was ever a
special thing in your life talk about it
in the comments and tell us like why
tell us why is it because there's more
than just one you know what I'm saying
it's it's that yes okay so I I will say
I do like the fact that like almost like
um almost like a Mentos or something
that as a kid you could throw it in your
jean jacket have a couple put it away
and have a couple later you can't really
put a bar back in the rapper once you do
it unless they go back to the foil I
think that
uh somebody wrote Rolo repugnance only
lives once it's kind of funny the uh no
okay so here were things that I liked
about the Rolo as a kid okay I liked
that it first of all had a the the logo
and the gold foil gave it a classiness
oh yeah gold foil is nice on anything
it's like the Ferrero Roch of children
there's something about Rollo like
rollos look very like the way it's
designed it looks very 1980s like it
would be next to like a bottle of conac
with like cigars and stuff there's
something about that design that's very
80s like business Manny okay so I like
that about it but I it was that there
and then it's obviously the chocolate
and caramel but I also did like that
there was more than one I had a big
thing as a kid with my snacks yeah uh I
was really obsessed with the of like my
food functioning like the way like Adult
food functioned like like what do you
mean by that like what do you think he
means I don't understand why you
laughing I'm imagining him as like a
teenager and mad men like a little mad
yeah yeah said your food want to
function the way like I'm talking eight
seven eight I'm talking young you mean
like you ate roll with a for KN what do
you mean not like what a for but like I
liked okay so like one one version of
this was having a supply of food that I
could go to when I chose to go to it
like a being able to eat some rollos and
have some in my room put them away for
later because like a grown-up would have
his own food to go to okay uh another
thing was yes any snack that resembled
like Adult food like like sometimes we
get these like I don't remember what the
hell they were they were like they were
like veggie rolls or something and they
were like they look like mozzarella
sticks but they had like vegetables
inside of them spring roll it was no it
wasn't that it was like it it was like
literally look monzer stick but it had
like chopped veget I don't I don't even
know what the hell they were but anyway
we used to eat those sometimes as kids
like that felt like like Adult food to
me didn't feel like a kids's food it was
like it felt sophisticated so anyway go
ahead I was going to say one of the
things that I would say about Rolo over
Butterfinger specifically is I like to
freeze my candy I like my candy cold I
like a cold candy bar and I do not like
swaying me back to Rolo I don't like a
frozen butter finger because actually
the consumption is I it's better for me
to consume a Rolo you pop one in I I'm a
big proponent of let it melt in your
mouth yeah I really am what's so funny
about
that it's just something you go to a lot
you twist it around in your hand you put
it in the side of your mouth you let it
sit yeah I like yeah it is now but also
too back in the day the rollos were
individually wrapped like that I mean
look it looks like gold yeah it looks
like you you found the treasure of some
kind well the thing is like you know I
like the I like peanut but
yeah I got to go back to Rolo actually I
Butterfinger is always a sticky like a
mess to me it's it's it's just a mess
and it doesn't after I eat the
Butterfinger I'm I'm all good about
halfway through and then afterwards I'm
like really I got to do work on my teeth
like I'm some type of hygienist peanut
britty like weird goo and also Bart
Simpson was the first Joe Camel of my
life where I ate Butterfinger strictly
because Bart was pushing it yeah and
then I ate it I'm like I hate this sh we
all saw what he ended up but you're team
Butterfinger you can't leave garbage no
I know but I mean I mean I'm just
attaching it because it's really yours
I'm attaching it for the sake of oh no
for the win and loss no problem I get it
are you or or were you or were you not
saying that to before we started the
battle I I forgot that it would this
would incur a win or loss so I was just
like I'll take this one but as you're
talking I'm getting convinced Rollo
neither one my candy Rolos are prone to
melt faster though they didn't they it
wasn't that hard kind of like I remember
it getting kind of like you get a little
Schmutz on can I say this actually maybe
just to to set a thing going forward too
because this happened last time too it's
hard to take one that I didn't want to
begin with and then get a loss from it
so I think in the future like or even
now if you're will willing if you're two
make it let's just talk about it but
it's a it's not a battle that has a win
or a loss to it that's fine the only
problem we'll run into is if we do a
bracket and you have too many losses
then you end up sitting out the yeah
we'll cross the bridge but yeah I mean
look right now if you don't want to take
an L on Butterfinger that's fine yeah I
I truly don't know who's going to win I
defend either but Butterfinger might win
but I still don't need the win either
cuz it's not my candy so I think Mike's
making some great points about rollos
that I did not think of uh I love it and
you know we're saying a lot less about
Butterfingers it sounds like we're all
team Rolo at this point I just I just
realized that after after I'm done with
a Butterfinger I realized that like it's
there's like this annoying whole thing
that has to happen afterward where I'm
getting that stuff out of my teeth the
Butterfinger is great I would argue
almost that the Fifth Avenue is the
superior version of the Butterfinger fth
Avenue same thing that's the cat lack of
Butterfingers The Fifth Avenue yeah
Fifth Avenue you don't remember Fifth
Avenue they were really good oh yeah
that's yeah it was but it was butterer
there yeah yeah can I tell you real
quick before we move on I had a job in
college at Manchester candy and tobacco
it was literally a warehouse with no
windows and a slow ceiling fan and my
job was to take boxes and fill orders
for like grocery stores and convenience
stores around the area so I'd walk up
aisles of cigarettes and candy that's
literally all we sold and they had all
these boxes of like you know bad candy
or whatever is like a day expired and we
would just take home literal like full
boxes of all the candy that sounds like
a child's dream it was in college so we
would I'd come home and just like dump
like hundreds of candy bars out and just
literally it just rained I traded candy
for weed many times wow but it was
interesting cuz I went through a lot of
these that I never I was Snickers we
away for candy well you know when people
get stoned you know the people really
want the candy it's like yeah literally
yeah just b h hit and here's it yeah and
I would just time my delivery of the
candy to like when they were leaving I
me someone at TI is literally like I'll
give you anything for that Cy exactly
yeah all right let's oh sorry no no I
just say Rollo is like that that's what
I had those so what do you want do you
want to just keep butter finger and we
do a win loss do you want to just let it
go wait say again do you want me to keep
Butterfinger it'll count as win loss it
doesn't have to count as a win loss I'm
fine it could win too but that's what
I'm saying I don't even care about to
win I think it's yeah yeah we can keep
it yeah neutral okay so we got over
4,000 votes I think Butterfinger is
going to
win I don't know I'm glad we both if R
goes into the final I thought it was
going to be the last seed folks prize
picks it's a fun not a fun name to say
prize pick prize pick is the largest
daily fantasy sports platform in North
America we're going to call it DFS from
here on out uh it's the easiest and most
exciting way to play DFS
and why CU it's just you against the
numbers you're not playing against other
people cuz when you play against other
people sometimes there's pros in there
there's sharks in there and worst of all
there's other people in there I don't
want to play against other people uh you
simply pick more than or less than on a
two to six player stat projection and
watch the winnings roll in that's it
it's easy uh you can play alongside
other people this is a new feature they
have uh if you want to play alongside
prize pick's favorite players like
rapper Meek Mill uh or comedian Andrew
Schultz buddy of ours uh you can now
find Community plays under the promo tab
of the app and view entries from some of
the biggest names in the prize pick
Community each week prize pick even
offers a reboot policy so that if your
entries stay in play even if one of your
players gets injured that's it you stay
in play even if one of your entries gets
injured for football and basketball
games if you have a player who exits the
game in the first half and does not
return to the second the player is
rebooted prize pick is the only DFS
platform with an injury insurance policy
folks what can I say even a guy like me
who doesn't understand Sports
understands how good this is so go to
priz picks.com tastebuds use code
tastebuds for a first deposit match up
to $100 again prize pick prize picks
again prize picks.com tastebuds and use
code taste buds for a first deposit
match up to
$100 prize picks folks Jo to Rosa here I
got some live dates coming up I'd like
to tell you about why not uh I'm doing a
special show on November 9th at the KGB
bar New York City as part of the New
York Comedy Festival the show's called
selected readings where I'm going to be
reading excerpts from my audio book The
Penthouse papers released on uh a
special thing records and I'm also going
to be reading some other stuff I
published over the years I'm looking
forward to that then I'm hitting the big
open road getting out of my own town
where I live and I'm coming to you with
what I Never Promised You a Rose Garden
live the new hour very proud of this
show November 11th hit in Philadelphia
PA theater of the Living Arts November
17th Pittsburgh PA at Bottle Rock at
Social Hall November 18th Buffalo New
York theater at senica 1 the 30th of
November Denver Colorado at the summit
December 1st Phoenix Arizona at the
Crescent par ballroom and December 3rd
Salt Lake City Utah at the soundwell
folks we're adding dates all the time
but for these dates and ones we might
add later you can go to joa.com for
Ticket links and show information and of
course if you are in New York City and
you want to check out my establishment
Joey roses come on down we're open 7
days a week 11:30 a.m. every day we open
those doors for affordable booze and
delicious affordable sandwiches Joey
roses nc.com what's up guys real quick
tour dates are on sale right now at
salvano comedy.com there's a big
Illinois run in November leading up to
my comedy special at the Vic in Chicago
on December 1st and 2nd I think Rolo I
don't know let's
see all
right Butterfinger I feel like
Butterfinger was just more in your face
a lot as a kid like I feel like you had
to seek out Rolo yeah you know what I
mean I remember
now here's the problem so for the listen
here's the problem yeah if crunch goes
to the finals now I'm I'm happily taking
Butterfinger if Milky Way goes to the
finers we got a little predicament here
I don't know what to do all right I
would take out of those two I would take
probably take Butterfinger but I don't
really care uh but just for the for the
listeners Butterfinger won
decisively an even 60% to rollos 40%
that's insan think you're like way more
popular than I think maybe it is I think
we're giving it enough Butterfinger was
Simpsons Bart Simpson sold Butterfinger
a finger on my Butterfinger it also had
one of the candy bars that still you the
campaign resonates I don't remember
seeing rollos at the at the checkout to
be honest with you I always got mine in
the 7-Eleven candy aisle yeah that's
always where but I got all my candy at
7-Eleven we my dad would it was like a
special trip like when it was time that
you were loud de candy we would go to
7-Eleven and I could go down the candy a
and pick like three things but that was
like once a week little things in life
it is the little things I know and then
my cousin once got a Slurpee as one of
his
things and I
C you were allowed to get three packages
of candy you could get three things that
you were allowed to consume that day as
well yeah wow oh wow that's lack it was
like one but it was like it was like
child abuse Friday night like it was
like Friday like we're going to rent
movies bouncing off the wall okay got
you I got you so uh but is it shared no
it's just you get you get three see so
that's why so when you went got rollos
did you go go rollos then a lot of times
I would go roll you get more than three
yeah technically see that was exactly I
was always thinking back but I remember
once we did it and my cousin got a
Slurpee as one of his things and I cried
cuz I was like I should have got a
Slurpee and then my dad my dad pulled me
aside and he goes just think about it
like this you're going to have some left
over tomorrow that's going to be all
gone right right away and then I cried
cuz I felt sorry for my
cousin what an empath you were crying no
matter what that day mess if I got three
things it would have been a newspaper a
black coffee and a pack of cigarettes
when I was nine that's great you were a
a coffee drinker as a kid yeah oh I I I
didn't drink coffee till I was like I
used to love my first cup was like at 18
and I you want know how I learned I like
coffee my My grandmother used to have
the the Italian cookies you dunk in
coffee what the S's and I used to eat
those and those made me like coffee I
just thought it was part for the course
they're coffee Treats but that was like
taking a sip off of beer when I was a
kid was like all you know Grandma's I
used to mom used to make me when I was
little she'd make me like I wouldn't
drink the coffee but she'd make me a cup
with cream and sugar in it and then make
me toast with butter and you dunk the
toast of butter in oh yeah I've seen
that yeah so good so good all right so
so so this next one here we're going to
just get through these it's Nestle
Crunch versus Milky Way Nestle Crunch is
my only candy remaining um I do think
Nestle Crunch is going to win uh this
battle uh there is how many votes I
4,000 it'll I bet you it hits 4 4,000
before 4,000 let's read some
phones n uh is this a trick Milky Way is
no
treat uh couple of powerhouses I'm not
I'm giving the nod to Milky Way I feel
bad for voting against Milky Way but I
truly like both Nestle Crunch love those
little chocolate rice things
uh pick for the milkway Nestle Crunch is
like when white people add pepper to
chicken and make to make it spicy that's
funny uh
uh see this is what I was saying about
Crunch bar it is it like many of the
foods we discuss it is dropped off I
would say that for everything these days
though so can I tell you one of the
reasons why I would prefer Nestle Crunch
why because I'm a weirdo where I want to
like put stuff on stuff so I would dip
into peanut butter with a nestly Crunch
bar because it's more of like a spoon
that's admirable then like I'm not going
to dip a you know what I mean I'm not
going to dip a mil way I like that it's
ambitious yeah it is and I just feel
like it's a vehicle for another thing to
eat wild you were creating your own
candy I moved a lot when I was a child
so I just tried to find my joy when I
could you know what I mean so eat all
everything you can before someone takes
if you would have thrown a uh if you
would have thrown some peanut butter in
there I think you would had yourself a
homemade Whatchamacallit I think exactly
yeah look at this
statement this is very important okay
very relevant Milky Way is the poor
man's Three
Musketeers that is crazy to me also was
it cheaper no we we we describe what
this was I thought Three Musketeers was
the low end of that ladder milky ways is
the poor man's Three Musketeers he's
saying milk Three Musketeers is superior
to the Milky Way WR that's what I'm
saying that's an insane thing to say all
Milky Way is is a Three Musketeers with
caramel it's a little more than that but
you know uh you know but but but that's
I I don't understand how somebody would
look at a Three Musketeers as the
superior of anything well he's he's he's
wrong that's why I love except the which
I they're changing the song they went
the nestly crunch song with Milky Way at
the
end uh all right what do you have
anything to to to argue about past what
you said about dunking into the peanut
butter I'm a crunch guy I like the
crunch I like different consistencies I
like a crunch I like a snap I like Rice
Krispies for that reason uh I Nestle
Crunch is mine right crunch chocolate
covered styrofoam
packaging I like a crunch I agree with
what one of the P people said earlier
it's netley crunch at one point was a
Crispy Crunchy kind of poppy experience
and it fell off it's just
chewy it's like the steer the cereal in
it now feels almost stale to me like
it's like the crunch part is gone it's
just like oh that's everything right I
just read anyone who enjoys Milky Way
should be put on a watch list I thought
that was
nice and I I don't get this nou nougat
is a horrifying proposition and it needs
other junk to back it up yeah but but
that I can't stress this enough just
because it's not awesome by itself
doesn't mean it's not a valuable
ingredient it's like saying it's like
saying eating ketchup straight is
disgusting no [__] but if I on fries
though but if I didn't have if I didn't
have nougat for the rest of my life I
wouldn't care I could sacrifice nougat
in my life and also it's my least
favorite ingredient in any candy bar
what the I'm not saying it's I I can't
eat it but like it's it does nothing
what is the cousin of nougat is
butterscotch the cousin of nougat is
caramel the cousin of nougat now we
actually confused once we looked it up
once like what is it it's like a malt I
think it's malt flavor it's fun to say
it is a great word noug I'll say nougat
all day long but I don't like yeah I
believe it's malt flavor malt flavor
like Whoppers or malt malt balls they're
called that's the kind of that that
flavor is nougat The Malt part really I
never would have I never would have
called malt balls nougaty nou nou I just
don't know what it is noui it's even
more fun than nou nou should we let's go
where you going babe where you going on
this n crunch n crunch n crunch 4,000
votes is oh my god
wow I
I remember remember this goes down to
decimal places which means that it's the
second Dead Heat in the history of taste
bus the other the only other Dead Heat
was about two years ago is egg salad
versus uh versus tuna salad but tell the
audience what happened we just got up
and took a lap because why is Nestle
Crunch oh that's what you voted for okay
this remember this goes down to the
tenth of a point right the tenth of a
point this is 50.0 to 50.0 after
3,891 votes a complete dead on tie I
don't even know what to do I don't know
what to do either I don't know what to
do to vote do you
know do you know also what this means I
mean it's this is down to the 100 it's
50.0 versus 50.0 that has never happened
that's happened one time what was the
other thing that happened with I forget
salad versus did you just say that I
didn't hear you say it I'm sorry I was
laughing when you said it sorry the uh
do you also realize what this means do
you realize what this means why
Butterfinger just took the candy bracket
Butterfinger just won oh wait wait look
it oh well we can't n that doesn't count
we can't we it's initial it's the first
thing yeah but it's a tie I don't know I
I think that shipping everybody out of a
final battle do you want to do this do
you want to put a pin in it and then let
this run its 24-hour pole course and
then in the next episode we'll just do a
quick finale we'll do a quick finale to
start the app but we'll still have
another so this is what we're going to
do this is what I think we should do
yeah butter finger let's name it it is
one the it is one okay but hear me out
hear me out
we also put a pin in the one of the
potato battles because it was so
close remember we threw one up late but
I want to see the winner of this vers
Butterfinger though what I'm well okay
cuz what I was going to say is is we
should do an episode where we do the two
dead heat from the tournaments this one
and the one that there was one from
potatoes that was so close we said let
it run 24 hours and then we'll see where
it's at yeah and we also we could also
Revis we can do the the one episode with
the three basically 50/50s okay and we
we could just we could do that to sort
it out what I think we should do here is
I think Butterfinger is in the finals I
think we let this run it's 24-hour poll
and if it's 50/50 at the end of 24 hours
Butterfingers I mean Butterfinger wins
but if not I think we'd pick this up um
in the next episode we start with it we
get the champ out and then we' still do
whatever so then how how much of a
disparity between percentages need does
needs to be any well but I'm saying if
we come back at 24 hours and it's that
you're saying you you're going to take
that and say 50.1 Milky Way goes I guess
it's it's a win I guess right I I was
going to say like there we
3% maybe what do we do if then it's just
Butterfinger I don't I I how about it's
got to be above 05% of a difference okay
but I but I don't you want to see one of
these then battle it's so interesting to
me now yeah yeah I do I'm just saying if
we come back in 24 hours and it's I got
an idea I got an idea I don't know I
don't know what I'm saying right now but
check this out if we come back in 24
hours and this is within this close of
it why don't we do just for the fun of
it just to see we'll do Butterfinger
versus each of
them okay or we could do a three-way
Poll for the champ put all three in the
pole okay that's that's how you should
do it okay if it's still too close or
you could just say look whatever the
winner is the winner is and we you know
yeah unless well I yeah if I mean I mean
if it's 50/50 then we do a three-way but
if it's if it's 50 50.1 it's 50.1 and
then what happens is that faces butter
finger okay and we'll we'll we'll
finalize it we'll name the champ in the
next app okay that sounds good when's
your special come out November 9th right
now it's out at 800p gm.com you can pay
what you want uh November 9th it's free
on YouTube you can enjoy all three of
these candies while you click view And
subscribe on YouTube m i k fi n o i a
thank you very much
uh we both still love each other I don't
know what's happening here we love each
other all right we love each other stay
tuned for the next step taste buds they
com to the mic talking about the food
they hate talking about the food they
like two fools going to fight but only
one food can be right taste buds man
yeah they coming to the